- Welcome to Late Night Show
(laughs).
(crowd cheering)
Which, ironically, is actually
filmed early in the morning.
- Yes.
- We won't talk
about that right now.
- They all are.
- Are they really?
- Yeah, I've been on all of
them,
they're all at
2:30 in the afternoon.
- So I don't even
feel weird anymore.
- Nope, this is normal.
- Well, this is GaryVee.
This is a big moment for us,
we've been waiting for you.
- Thank you.
- We've got our Idealogue
Show happening today.
- Yup.
- And Gary's going to be
the keynote speaker.
- Can't wait.
- We thought we would squeeze
in a little late night taping
of you to get some of the
down and dirty,
you know, who is GaryVee?
- Thrilled to do it.
- I did bring, because
I know you're a big Jets fan--
- I am.
- And I brought
Ryan Fitzpatrick's
really bad clone double.
- Yes, I see him.
- He's here.
His name's Mike,
and he's our sidekick.
- (laughs) Hey Mike.
- He's a huge fan of yours.
- Glad to see you, sir.
- Oh, oh, oh,
very nice, very nice!
- Thank you Mike, thank you.
- You know, Ryan's benched
this week, so I guess he has
some downtime, unfortunately.
- Yeah.
He's got a lot of downtime.
- Hurts, hurts.
- I guess my first question--
- Yeah.
- Before we get into
the nitty gritty is--
- Sure.
- Why the Jets?
- You know, I was born
in the Soviet Union.
We came here when I was three.
- Are the Jets big out there?
- No, the Jets are
not known out there.
- Oh.
- But, I came in the late 70s.
You know, when I first kind
of, you know, this is the
late 70s, early 80s, kids
went outside and played,
it was a different generation
when I first went out,
I didn't, I wasn't Americanized,
I didn't have that common bond
with the kids outside and,
one early, you know,
one day in first grade,
there was a group of
kids playing football,
they asked me what my
favorite football team was,
I said, I'm not even sure if
I remember if I spoke English
all that much, and they said,
"Well, you're a
Jets fan like us."
And I was like, "Okay."
And basically that Sunday,
I watched my first Jets game,
and I have not missed a play,
a play, of a
New York Jets game since 1982.
- Unbelievable.
- Yup.
(audience applause)
I lived in New York
for most of my life.
- Yes.
- And now I'm down in Florida.
- So I'm having a difficult
time cause I was a Giants fan--
- Yes.
- Here in the city, and
then went down to Miami,
and I'm not doing
so well, either.
- With the Dolphins.
- Yup, so we've got
a lot of work to do--
- Yup, I understand.
- On both of our teams.
- It's bad times in football.
- Yeah, seriously (laughs).
You don't play fantasy
football do you?
- You know what's funny,
I've never played,
this is my first season.
Cris Collinsworth, who has
this kind of celebrity-serious
league, and so, I did it
for branding, to be honest.
I'm five and one.
- Woah!
- Because like most
things, I'm very talented.
No, I'm just just kidding
(laughs).
But I don't like to
play it because I think,
you have to understand,
my life is very simple.
The health and
happiness of my family,
the New York Jets,
my business.
- In that order.
And so, I'm a simple man.
And the Jets are truly,
this is not a joke,
the Jets are my true escapism.
I take it very seriously,
but I have it contextualized
of what it means in
the scheme of things.
It's the one thing in the
world that I care enough about,
that if something bad is
happening in business,
it is not in my mind
in those four hours,
and that's healthy, and
I think we all need that,
whether that's reading,
meditation, traveling,
I know mine's weird, but it
doesn't make it any less real,
and I need that escapism,
and it's tough when a
season like this happens--
- Yeah.
- When a game's become
kind of not as important.
- Yeah.
- I'm not as invested.
But I go, and I watch,
and I support--
- Yeah
- Yeah, it's a big deal for me.
- Yeah.
Gary--
- Yes.
- What is the most valuable
asset today, in the world?
- Attention.
- Okay.
If we're talking the context
of who I know is watching.
Before you can tell me how
great you are at your craft,
or how great your product is,
or why I should come and see
you, you need my attention.
And so if you're talking, in
a place where the end consumer
is no longer
paying attention to,
you're in deep shit.
And so when you're spending
an ungodly amount of money on
direct mail, or outdoor
media, or television,
or traditional digital like
banner ads, or pre-rolls,
I don't think that's as valuable
a move as something like
what you're doing right now,
which is a content play,
or Facebook, or Instagram,
or Snapchat,
and so, I've been pulling the
levers of attention since
I was a six-year old,
trying to sell lemonade,
and trying to figure
out which pole or tree
to put my sign on that would
sell more cups of lemonade.
I used to think about how
I would, this is funny,
this is perfect, I used
to do baseball card shows,
and I would literally sit there,
and people used to
think I had some sort of
either weird disease, or was
like super, kind of like,
you know, wired in a weird way,
'cause I would sit and think
about the layout of my cards
for two hours before
the mall would open,
and then would watch how
people would look at my table.
I've been following
attention my whole life.
When I was dragged in
my dad's liquor store,
when I was 14, and started
working there, you know,
there were some of the guys
that thought I was weird
because I wasn't working,
but all I was doing was just
literally watching the pattern
of how somebody would
walk through the store.
Later I understood the
biggest retailers in the world
had cameras following
us and understood UI/UX,
and all this stuff,
or the shelf at a bar,
why are those products there,
but that came to me as
natural as you can imagine.
It is my natural gift to
understand where consumers'
attention is, a little bit
faster than the marketplace,
which has been the
foundation of my success.
- Crazy.
Do you, how valuable
to you is time?
- I mean, it's the
whole thing, right?
I mean, when I--
- You are--
- I talk a lot about time.
- I don't think I've
ever seen anyone as...
You wake up early
in the morning.
You do 15 minutes is
kind of your max, right?
- Yeah, I mean I think, and
I don't know what else to say.
I mean I think all of
us here in this studio,
everybody watching at home
like, time is the game.
Like you can do
anything you want,
you can have all the money,
success, connections,
nobody's figured out how
to add that 25th hour.
And yeah, I think time
is super important.
You know, Uber, my investment
Uber was a big one.
I passed on Uber
in the angel round,
which would've been ungodly.
- Wow, wow.
- You know, really tough
to say that publicly
that I left those
$300 million on the table.
Not only did I pass on
it, I passed on it twice.
Not only that, it gets worse,
my first business
book Crush It!,
I thank my entire family
and one random human being,
the co-founder and
CEO of Uber, Travis,
who's a dear friend of
mine for a long time.
I didn't understand it,
the first time.
When I invested in a little
bit later, so I'll do okay,
I realized, holy shit, Uber
doesn't sell transportation,
Uber sells the
perception of time.
And I believe that any
company in today's world
that takes time and
resells it back to people
will build the biggest
companies in the world.
And so even the way
I think about advertising,
if you're trying to, if
I'm trying to watch this
YouTube video but
you put a banner,
a pre-roll before it
you stole my time.
I came here to watch this,
not to see this
car driving up a hill.
And so, time is the asset.
By the way, by a small group
here, by show of hands,
I know everybody
can't see this at home
but I'll do color
commentary for you.
By show of hands,
how many people here
are now mad when another
human being calls them?
Raise your hand.
- It's rude.
It's just downright rude.
- Think about that.
Half this room just
raised their hands.
Think about asking that
question 10 years ago.
It just wouldn't
have even made sense.
We now know there's other
ways to use technology.
Like, you text me, and I'll
get back to you on my time.
That's why it's rude.
And so time has become
the thing that we've put on
a pedestal because for
some of us in this room,
we're not 18-year-olds,
we're not 16-year-olds,
we remember the world
when it used to actually
shut off at 6
or 7 P.M. professionally.
And you'd get to it tomorrow.
That world does not exist.
You get people emailing
you at 11 P.M. there's some
sort of expectation that
you may get back to them.
We live in a 24/7/365 world
where we're pounded
by information.
So now we, subconsciously,
we've formed
into this enormous belief
and value around time
and it's precious and
I do reverse engineer a lot
of my strategies around
how to not steal time.
- That was actually
one of the questions.
- Which is?
- So based off this
concept of time--
- Yes.
- being such a valuable
asset, right, for you?
- Yes.
- For everybody.
- It helps to prioritize
what you invest in,
what you spend money in
your business on,
what are the things
that are going to get you
the most out of your time?
- You know it's funny,
I think of it
almost in reverse of that.
Yes, that's all true and you
can list all the other things.
It makes me
overwhelmingly focused
on not wasting the
other person's time.
Because then I'm
bringing the most value.
The keynote I'm about to give,
it's not a canned speech,
I think you know that.
I know who's in the audience.
You know, and
I'm gonna think about what
can I talk about that's gonna
bring them the most value?
Yesterday morning in
Orlando at the ANA,
where it's the biggest TV
advertisers in the world,
I talked about something
completely different.
So, that's predicated on
actually valuing people's time.
I don't want them to
sit there for 45 minutes
and zone out,
or not get any value.
They're sitting there.
Even this interview,
I'm like obsessed
at the highest level of, "Okay,
who's watching this show?
"Got it, that demo, what can
I say that's practical to them
"that they can take away
and do something with?"
And I just do that
with my employees,
with my customers,
with my audience.
And I think that's
why I'm successful.
Because if you bring more value
than you ask for in return,
you win in life,
let alone business.
- Yeah, I've always thought,
you know,
hairdressers are interesting.
And I think the service
industry as a whole
is an interesting kind of beast
as this whole time
and social media.
And what you said, it's so true,
everyone's bombarding you
for information and time.
They're trying to
steal it from ya, right?
Whether it's
banner ads or whatever.
But a hairdresser
has 45 minutes?
- Well, you know what's funny?
- So how do you, what's your--
- It's funny where
you went with that.
I think, and you guys know this
better than I do, but I know
this as a common sense, savvy
human individual on Earth.
I think people really
enjoy, some, their time,
and by the way you have to
reverse everybody one by one.
You have to have the EQ
skills and the empathy
to understand is this
person really valuing time
and wants to get out of here?
And if I can do this in 37
minutes instead of 44 minutes,
I'm gonna actually
make them happy.
And then there's other
people who are running
a mile a minute and this
is a time to kind of let go
and enjoy and escape into
your guys' world with them.
And maybe that
should be 49 minutes.
I think the place that
you guys need to focus on
as an industry is not
necessarily the execution
of your craft and your art but
how one gets to that moment.
I don't want to
waste my time to book.
I don't want to waste
my time to like chase
or the infrastructure
to get them there,
or discover you, is where you
need to completely save time.
Once they're there,
now you're getting
into an entire experience thing.
I think you could
go the other way.
I think you could have
somebody, I think people are.
Somebody like me,
if this is something that
they're passionate
about, would rather spend
an hour and a half in the
experience, but save two
out of the four minutes on
the execution to get there.
- You're so spot on,
because right now there is a,
it's almost like a clash,
it's what,
when you talk
about what happened
in the wine business-
- Yes.
- That same kind of
renaissance, or clash,
is happening now, you're
having an older generation
of hair stylists-
- Yes.
- That is 100% focused
just on the craft-
- Yes.
- And the quality of that
customer service experience.
- Yes.
- But then you have this
new, young generation-
- Yes.
- Mostly millennial driven-
- Okay.
- That have kind of popped up,
and they're using social
media to get their clients.
- Yes.
- They're using social media
to get people in the chair.
- Yes.
- Where in the old school
days, you had to go
and actually hand business
cards out on the street,
or wait for your
customers that you cut
to tell other people to
come to you for a haircut.
But now you're
getting people that,
three years in the business,
they're booked 20 a day,
six months out, and they're
charging $800 a haircut.
It's actually happening--
- Of course it's happening.
- So what that's done is it's
upended the entire industry,
so the things you're talking
about are all kinda playing out
- Technology is a
son of a bitch.
- Yeah.
- Technology doesn't care
that you've been unbelievable
at your craft for 30 years.
- Right.
- Technology didn't care
that my dad's contemporaries
that came over from Russia
in 1978, moved to L.A.
made two bucks an
hour being a cab driver,
worked 20 hours a day, saved
every dollar for 13 years,
had paid their dues,
didn't see their family,
saved all their money,
bought a couple of black cars,
actually built the business,
saved all their money,
worked every day for 30 years,
finally getting to the moment
where eating all that shit
might pay off,
just a little bit,
and then Uber came along and
put them out of business.
- Totally, totally.
- Technology didn't care
that your grandfather
came from Europe, worked 80
hours a day for his whole life,
built a small little bookstore,
your dad came along,
your mom came along,
made it bigger,
now it was your turn,
and it's a real great base,
and you were gonna take it,
and Amazon came along and
put you out of business.
Technology just doesn't care.
- Yeah.
- Like, I don't know
what to tell you,
this is called capitalism,
this is the way it works.
I understand how you
want it to be romantically,
I understand that
you want it to be
in your best vested interest.
Do you know how
mad I am that Twitter
is not the number one
social network in the world?
From 2007 to 2011
I spent 14 hours a day
answering people's
questions on Twitter.
Let me just say
this one more time.
There's people watching, a
couple people know this truth,
for you, you just
don't believe it
'cause it makes
no fucking sense.
(laughing)
- 14 hours a day
I spent on Twitter,
replying to anything
anyone said about wine,
and then for the back
half of a year or so,
business, and did it every day,
and became one of the 50 most
followed people on Twitter,
it was my breakout to the world.
Do you know how
amazing it would be for me
if Twitter was
Facebook right now,
and was the number one
platform in the world?
But it's not, and nobody's
crying for me,
and nobody's going
to cry for you,
and nobody's going to cry for
anybody, that's the point.
And so of course
that's happening.
- Yeah.
- This always happens.
- I mean, I don't understand
what people,
including the people that
got exposure from, you know,
what's the difference of
somebody hustling
on social media to
build their business,
and somebody doing a
good job 20 years ago,
and the New York Times
writing a piece about them?
Nothing. The only
difference is people now
can actually take full control
of the customer's intention
and not be at the
mercy of a middle man
and mainstream media, so yeah
of course it's happening.
- I love, you talk a lot
about the hustle.
- Yes.
- And I had seen
something the other day
where you talked about keep
that luck shit to yourself.
(Gary laughing)
Can you just talk
to that for a second,
'cause I think
it's really important.
- Yes.
- People often think it's-
- Yes, my high school friends
emailed me on Facebook,
and the opening line
is, "You're so lucky,"
and then I black out and
don't read anything else
and I reply to them and
say, "Rick, that's awesome,
"but I need to
remind you something.
"Remember in
high school and then college
"when you went
to the Jersey shore
"and drank a bunch of beers
and hooked up with chicks?
"I fuckin' worked."
- Right.
- So I'd prefer that
people keep that luck shit
in their pocket.
(laughter)
Which means, and by the way
I was born in the Soviet Union
because Khrushchev,
two Presidents
before I was even born,
came to America and saw corn
being planted everywhere,
and he was such an idiot
he went back to Russia
and planted corn in all
of the Soviet Union,
which it couldn't
actually work there,
and so that started
the process of them
having a resource issue,
which led to 1976,
them making a deal with
Israel and the United States
to get rid of Jews, which
they had no interest in
to begin with, out of Russia,
in exchange for wheat,
that is luck.
I was lucky to be born
at a serious event,
that I'm comfortable with.
- Right.
- There's a lot of
things, I believe in luck.
I just think it's a
tough thing to start with
when you talk to somebody
who basically,
since he was 14 years old,
has been working
15 hours a day, every day,
always and forever.
And as you know,
because I have a good
sense that you know this,
the reason DRock and
I started DailyVee,
my vlog, which
is now 80 episodes in,
is I talk about hard work,
I just realized
after four or five years that
people didn't believe me,
so now I just document it.
Really hard to debate when
I've got the hard footage
of 7A.M. to midnight,
every day, every day,
every day, every day-
- So he's with
you all that time?
- Yeah, poor guy.
- Wow.
(audience laughter)
- Yeah.
- Is there hazard pay?
(laughter)
- I mean the poor guy, by
the way the other thing is
I don't believe in that many
different things, right?
So I don't even know how
he gets through a day
of hearing the same shit,
but yeah I think
I believe in hard work.
Here's what I can tell you.
You, everybody watching at home,
you do not know
a single person on Earth
that became successful
because of themselves,
without hard work,
they just don't exist.
- Yeah.
- They don't exist.
You know some people that
inherited Grandma's money,
and they're rich, but nobody
made themselves successful
without hard work, it just
doesn't, it's impossible.
- I do know that I need to
do a little history looking,
'cause I didn't know the
Jews were traded for wheat.
- Yes, we sure were.
- Of all the things
to get traded for-
- By the way, with the amount
of taxes that I've paid
in my life,
that was a great trade.
- Right (laughs). Wheat, wheat!
Especially if you're
very gluten free-
- Yeah I get it.
- It hits home.
- It was the seventies.
- Gary, another concept
you talk about,
I kind of want to
get some of these-
- Go ahead,
let's do it, I'll go faster.
- No these are great for
hairdressers, and no rush.
- Okay.
- You talk about, everyone
always talks about failing,
and you talk about being
scared of failing, to who?
And I love that,
I think 'cause that really
gets the essence of it.
- Yeah, that's been-
- And hairdressers
have a lot of fear
when they're cutting,
and getting into a job.
- Got it, that was a big one
that I didn't realize would,
I'm glad you picked up on that.
People are scared of failing,
I think we all know that.
I think everybody
understands that,
that's why so
many people don't try.
I just somehow
stumbled on
how lucky I was that my mom
is the greatest
human being on Earth,
and created a self esteem
for me that is, (chuckles),
probably somewhat
inappropriate, but shit,
I would not give
it up for anything
because it's made
me very comfortable.
I think that somehow,
some way, between DNA
and the way I was parented,
and my circumstance
of immigration,
things of that nature,
I'm in a funny place
where I'm just not scared,
I'm just not
worried about, you know,
I have this weird, I could
care less what anybody thinks,
and I genuinely care
what everybody thinks.
You know it's kind of
this real Ying and Yang
and so I just realized
that so many of you
are scared to fail because
your dad's gonna make
you feel bad about it.
And I have empathy
for that, that sucks.
Or your husband is gonna
say, "I told you so."
I'm very fascinated
by negative energy
within our ecosystem
that is not cut-outable.
You can get rid of
your acquaintance
that's a dick face, right?
(laughter)
But when your mom's the
dick face, you're in trouble.
- Yeah.
- And so I've been trying
to have this conversation,
of who are you
scared to fail in front of,
and I gotta tell you, in
one-on-ones or meet-ups,
where the content has come from,
that's the beauty
of doing a vlog.
- Yeah.
- Content happens
in these moments
that I would've never
thought of, it's captured,
it resonates, I react to the
reaction of the audience,
and I start trying to force
myself to understand it better.
- Right.
- Whoof! People are scared,
like you look up
to your older sister
who's straight line, and
her opinion matters to you,
but you're an artist
and you wanna do this,
and if you fail
you don't want to
fail in front of her.
That's tough,
that's stopping a lot of us.
I don't have the answer to
what you have to do about it,
other than I do believe that
communication solves all things
but great, how do I push
you to have that real talk
with your mom? Hard, so
yeah man, it's a real one,--
- Yeah.
- but it's not so
easy to unwind.
- Your blogs and your stuff.
That one actually really
resonated cause I was like
wow, this is deeper than
just social media tidbits.
- All my stuff.
- It's actually is really
deep when you get into it.
- All my stuff is very
strategic high brow,
like I'm a jersey in the
dirt kind of character.
So by being the messenger
of this very tried and true,
very historically correct,
very heady strategic stuff,
people are confused cause
I don't look the part.
I look the part of the
sizzle, not the steak.
- Mhmm.
- But that's the beauty
of running the marathon.
Eventually, even in
this interview like,
they'll be like, huh.
You know like eventually,
and I don't care if that takes
just one interview,
or the rest of my life.
I'm very comfortable that
what I'm selling is not
flash in the pits.
You have to understand, I spent
15 years building a business
before I was a personality.
I wasn't a 22 year old
life coach on Instagram.
I put my head down and
built a $65 million business,
you know, in the dirt,
in the trenches
working 15 hours
a day in a liquor store
and then building an
early e-commerce business
before I thought I had
the audacity or even the
respect or platform
to even think
that I was worth listening
to for 40 minutes, right?
- Love that.
- So I think I earned
it, and so I understand
my personality traits that
may make it seem like its
fast, is it real?
I'm empathetic to that, but.
- This next one
kind of rolls into that.
- Please.
- You talk about and I
just think its such good,
it's somewhat, these are
like good things for young
hairdressers to hear.
- Okay.
- The concept of
making Monday my bitch.
- (Laughing) Yes.
- You know, I love that.
- Okay.
- Because it, so many times
I just know in our business
when we were kind of growing
through the ranks and
hiring lots of people,
especially new people
where it's their first job,
they start to not like Mondays.
And it would drive me crazy,
as it drives you crazy.
Can you talk to that.
- Yeah I mean there's
nothing sadder in life
than if you live
for the weekends.
I just, it's just a math game.
If you're spending 83
percent of your time,
72 percent of your time,
64 percent of your time
on something you hate,
that's devastating.
I went through it,
I hated school at a
level that you couldn't imagine.
I was a rare version of an
immigrant that education
wasn't the way out.
And I knew who I was, I had
self awareness coming out
of my pores in fourth
grade, I knew it already.
And so, shit, eight more
years and when you're 11
that, like half your life.
It was devastating, like
Sunday nights were devastating.
A potential snowstorm was the
greatest moment of my life,
you know?
So I lived it, I lived it
as a kid not as serious
as being a grownup that
hates their job, no question.
But at the time
it felt serious, right?
And so I don't know,
we live in a age now
where your grandparents
couldn't do the things
you can do.
Your grandparents
didn't have the internet,
your grandparents
couldn't be practical
nine to five then
come home, you know,
do their family thing
and then from 7 P.M.
to two in the morning
do something online
that could have been the
thing that switched them
out of their nine to five,
and created their freedom.
They didn't have that option.
We do, everybody in
this room does.
We live in a 24/7 world.
Now, my big thing that leads
this into is complaining.
- Perfect.
- The thing that
rips my heart out
of my soul is complaining.
If you are genuinely unhappy,
if you're genuinely unhappy
do something about it.
The amount of
people that email me
and complain, and then I go
look at their social media,
and all they tweet about
is "Game of Thrones" and
FIFA Soccer, and I'm
like, what are you doing
with your time?
You are not allowed to
complain if you're on two
softball teams.
(laughter)
You're just not allowed.
So I think that, yeah,
the great positive
to being underestimated
for charisma
and showmanship,
is that you also have
motivational DNA
that actually allows
somebody who's
listening to be like, yes.
And that has been the
great gift of my life.
I struggle with my
motivational tendencies.
I don't want to be
Tony Robbins or Oprah
or a motivational character.
I'm much more in tune with
building actual businesses.
I don't like
"The Secret", you know.
Like I don't like that stuff.
However, however
it's very difficult to me
when I get 10 to 15
emails a day from
people like, you changed
my life, I watched this
video for some reason
I've heard it before,
but the way you
said it made me do this
and my life is
better whether it was,
have that
conversation with my mom,
or start a business.
And it's funny,
I've been going through
a very difficult time,
and I mean this.
And this is
a high class problem,
but for me, I've been
really struggling with,
I've come to realize
that me holding back
on my motivation
for the last five years
has been a selfish act,
you know, 'cause
I want to be known as a
businessman not as a guru.
But I've helped
so many more people
in the last six months
that I've opened
up a little bit
more of that, so it's an
interesting journey
right now for me on that.
- You know,
just on that piece, switching
gears for a second,
we'll come right back
to the nitty gritty.
- Yeah.
- You know, I was trying
to think to myself
of, and this
- Go ahead, go ahead.
- Is gonna sound really creepy.
How would I torture you?
- Torture me.
- And I came up with an idea.
- Well, not allowing
me to talk would.
- No, even better.
I was gonna to take
you and I to an island.
- Yes.
- And literally
drop us off with no wifi.
- Yes.
- No connectivity.
- Sounds romantic.
- Yeah, it is a little strange.
(laughter)
- How would you,
what would that do?
Would that literally
shut you down?
- I think I'm a chameleon.
Here's what would happen.
- Or could you totally adapt?
- Correct,
I would be a disaster.
- In the beginning, then.
- Dead, like dead.
Like the first two,
three four five days
I'd be like eating
sand and like trying
to kill you with like a shell,
- Lord Of The Flies.
- That's right,
but by day 12, 14, 20
I would re-context.
- Okay, I'd just stay
away from you for the
first week or two.
- No I'd probably need you
more in the beginning, right?
- Wow, this is gonna be an
emotional weekend together.
- Because I need that
interaction, but over time
I think, yeah,
I mean I'm comfortable,
you know ironically,
ironically my two favorite
places are the
airplane and the bathroom.
'Cause I'm by myself.
I'm super, you know,
I love myself.
I could be with myself, and so.
- Do you disconnect often?
- No, no.
- I didn't think you did.
- But if I need to, it's
very easy for me to do that.
- Yeah.
- Got it.
You have to understand,
and this is just like
we're getting pretty heady here.
If you only thing in life
is the health of your
family, you're
pretty happy a lot.
- Yeah.
- Unfortunately,
you can get really sad.
You know like if
I get a text right now
that my sister's
in a car accident and
things are really bad, I'm shut
out in a way that you couldn't,
I don't know if
I ever come, I don't come
back until that's resolved.
- Right.
- So you know,
it's really easy to shut off
or shut on, or not like.
When you are as
binary as the health
and well being of my
family, comma nothing else,
then all the way over here
the Jets and then business.
- I love that this is
after the Jets, by the way.
- You know, it's really
easy to be happy
and I do challenge everybody to
start really building
perspective.
- Yeah.
- You know,
we really struggle with it.
We've lived during the
greatest, we lived during
the greatest era
of the greatest empire
of human race.
If an American,
if a white American male
does not realize
that they have won
the ultimate lottery
of the universe.
- Being alive.
- In America during
it's greatest era as an
empire, then I've
got nothing for them.
Like genuinely,
genuinely if I became
the dictator of America,
I would make it a
life sentence in jail
for a white American
male to complain at all.
- Yeah.
(laughter)
That'd be interesting,
I think, Putin's probably
on his way to becoming
dictator of America somehow.
- You might be right.
- He's like hacking
his way into it.
Talk about ROI.
- Return on investment.
- But you talk
about that a lot and
I love the way that you
kind of introduce it.
- You mean the ROI of
your mother statement,
or do you mean like,
look I mean ROI is like,
what's the return
on your investment?
I go through it
from a lot of ways.
Historically, and this
is more old school,
I used to always talk about
what's the ROI of your mother.
Everybody wants
to measure everything.
How do I,
like I can tell you that
I will literally buy
a multi-billion dollar
sports organization
one day of my life,
in 30 years, and the
complete ROI is the way
my parents parented me.
I can't quantify it,
I can't show you a chart
that on May 16th,
when I got this shitty haircut,
my mom still said I was the
best looking boy on Earth.
Like, I can't give
you that data point
but I know it happened and
I know what it did for me,
right?
So you know I can't
show you in a chart that
oh, on April 13th, 1986
I opened the door
for a woman at McDonalds,
this is a true story,
not the date,
but I opened the door for
an elderly woman
at McDonalds instead
of just running in, and my mom
spent the next 17 days acting
as if I won the
Nobel Peace Prize.
(chuckling)
You know, I can't show you that.
But I think about
ROI in a lot of places.
Look, return on investment.
First of all, I believe
that in the digital world
people are confused.
They may say Google's
working, but what they
don't realize was that it
was a video on Facebook
that made somebody search
for you on Google and
then click that ad.
Was that Google, no it wasn't.
Google's the toll
booth of society and it
gets credit for driving
your business way
more than it actually does it.
Right, ROI, I think
people do a lot of things
for the value of it today
instead of 23 years from now.
I'm not doing this
interview right now for
the value of your
viewership today.
I'm doing it for
the fact that it's in an
ecosystem that I'm not
as involved with, and
maybe 13 years from now
something of somebody
learning about me
today brings me value.
And even better,
I'm not even worried
about cashing in on that chip.
Bottom line is,
we live in a world where
99 percent of people
are running a sprint
and the reality is
that life's a marathon.
And that's that.
And so when I think about
ROI, I think of it in
short and long term.
I need some things to
get by right,
on a day to day basis.
I need money from
clients to pay for my
employees, like
I gotta pay rent.
I gotta run a P&amp;L but
the amount of people
that draw lines in the sand,
spec work.
I'm not gonna cut this
person's hair for free
even though they're
famous or important
this and that.
That's the stupidest
thing of all time.
That word of mouth
could be exponential
to the growth of your business.
But people draw religious lines
in the sand on
ideological notions that
destroy the upside
of their long term.
- Love that,
your book
'cause were actually,
I think giving,
we gave a copy to every
that's coming to the
Idealogue event.
- Thank you.
- And this is your,
I think your third.
- Are we talking about
#AskGaryVee?
- Yeah.
- My fourth.
- Your fourth.
- My fourth New York
Times best selling book.
(laughter)
By the way that was for
all my English teachers
that gave me D's and F's because
they are spinning right now,
like how the fuck
did that happen?
- He writes?
(laughter)
- Barely...
- Can you just give us
the highlights of the book
because obviously
for hairdressers,
we would love for them
to go and buy the book
and kinda start educating.
- I mean it's the state
of the union of marketing
and entrepreneurship
and operations.
My state of the union.
I do a YouTube show
called #AskGaryVee,
I take questions from social
media and I just answer them,
and there's
chapters on parenting
while being somebody
who's super ambitious.
And there's questions
on tactics on Pinterest
to drive a transaction.
And so it's an all
encompassing state of the union
of the things that
have made me successful
and the things that have made
people want to follow me,
but the most encompassing;
the other three books
were very, very business driven,
there was a lot more EQ,
leadership,
dealing with stress.
It was a very more rounded...
- That there was some change...
And look I mean
we all know this, right?
As hot shot as
I thought I was at 25
I'm a much stronger better
version of myself at 40.
Experience actually matters,
it's real
and I feel like
I'm becoming more in tune
and tapping into
some of the subtleties
that have made
me successful other than
the black and white tactics.
And by the way
when I say successful
I'm gonna recall it
'cause it's important.
I make money, I could
make a lot more money
if I was willing to
be less successful.
When I mean successful
I mean the balance
of being more proud about
how you make your money
than how much you make.
On the balance of being more
worried about your legacy
than your currency.
On the balance of thinking
about what your grandkids
are gonna think of
you and most of all,
the number one
way I run my life,
how many people can I guilt
into coming to my funeral.
- That's what you're
thinking about?
- That is the number one
way that I live my life.
If you ask me what my
global North Star is,
my entire game is predicated
on how many people
show up to my funeral.
Because showing
up to funerals actually...
And it's interesting,
I no longer like the Yankees
and the Rangers.
I'm going in a little bit
of an interesting direction.
- It's good, I'm liking this.
(laughter)
- Cause both those teams
won Championships for me.
So, now I obsess over
the Knicks and the Jets.
I love the climb.
I love the journey.
And it was interesting,
as this funeral things
started happening
over the last ten years,
I was like,
"Wait a minute, that's
the ultimate journey."
"My whole life is this
journey, the pay off is
"the funeral and
I don't even get to know
"how it plays out."
- (Laughing) You're
not even there.
- I'm not even there.
So, I think it's fascinating,
I've been fascinated
by the funerals
that I've gone to and
the ones that I haven't
as I become more
busy and travel.
And it's really
predicated on heart
over brain or wallet
or other things, right?
And so, yeah man.
- That's deep.
- I think so.
- Gary can you
talk to the fact that
Millennials are...
It's just a generation
and they understand
efficiency naturally.
- Yes.
- It's something that
just kinda comes to them.
- Yes.
- And how older generations
can easily adapt
and thrive by doing so.
Cause you're not a Millennial.
- Yeah I think this Millennial,
even when you
brought it up earlier,
I think this
Millennial talk is whack.
Let me tell you why.
I have
600 or so,
500 of our 800
employees at
VaynerMedia are under 28.
And 25% of them
only care about working
all day and night and making
as much money as possible.
And then I know
48-year-olds that want
work-life balance...
Stereotypes have truths,
I respect that,
but all of this is
always a mindset.
This is a mindset, this
isn't how old you are.
This is how you are wired.
And I think that Millennials
have gotten a bad rap
for their work ethic
and for their audacity
and there's plenty of them.
But there was plenty of those
people 20 years ago, too.
We just didn't categorize them.
I've run
businesses for a long time.
20 years ago long before
there was Millennials
there was plenty of 25-year-olds
that came into my business
that thought that should
be running the company.
That's a DNA trait.
That is not an age thing.
- It's just kind of this
label that's been put.
- On the older generation
let's call it 35 and above
there's a lot of
excuses going around.
"Well I didn't grow
up with this stuff."
No shit, you didn't
grow up driving either
and you learned.
(laughter)
We learn things.
I think what happens is
a lot of people are lazy
and get tired and are burnt out
and they don't
want to put in the work.
Blows my mind that
everybody watching here
isn't willing to watch
or read for 20 hours
about Facebook,
Instagram, Snapchat,
these platforms that are the
relevancy of our society.
You can literally watch 20
hours of YouTube videos on
how do I run Facebook ads,
you just type it in
and you now know especially
if you actually do it
while you, not just read it.
And so literally, I don't know,
in a week anybody in the world
that has the
capacity to learn,
It's more about
understanding how you learn.
Do you need to listen,
do you need to watch,
do you need to read?
Can actually be very
strong at all this stuff,
the punchline is,
people like excuses.
People don't wanna
put in the work.
That's fine, more for me.
- The concept of fast follower.
- Yes.
- Can you talk to that?
- Yeah, I think fast
follower's a good model.
You see something
that's successful,
just moving quickly and
trying to learn from
those behaviors is
very, very interesting.
Lyft, Lyft's a very
big business,
they didn't invent Lyft,
they saw Uber and they're
like, "I don't know,
"We don't think Uber's
gonna get everything."
Google.
Google saw Yahoo!.
Facebook, do you
remember Myspace?
Fast following is good.
- Gary, we've only got
a couple of minutes
so I'm kinda prioritizing
my list of 7,000 questions.
- Please.
What is your
definition of wisdom?
- I'm not sure.
- Okay moving on,
do you collect anything?
- Do I collect anything?
Yes.
- I saw something, so that's
why I asked you the question.
- I used to collect
a lot of things,
but I always bought
things just to sell them.
As a matter of fact,
I'm in a really bad mood
'cause it looks like
it's gonna rain tomorrow
and I can't take
my kids garage saling
and like buy...
Buying something for
25 cents at a garage sale
and selling it for $4.80 on eBay
gives me a bigger
high than landing
a $5 million account.
- Okay I just wanna stop
on that for one second.
I don't think people realize
that he's not joking.
- The thrill of the hunt.
- That you actually do that.
- I did it last weekend.
- He buys stuff and he
sells it online for more.
- I get a lot of
emails from people
who are like, "I'm on
welfare, I'm homeless,"
I get emails, "I'm homeless,
"I'm a single mom
with four kids."
A lot of people,
my Silicon fancy friends
are not emailing me
these are a lot of people
that are watching my content
someway somehow, who a
$100 a week
is life changing.
I know this my sound
very weird, but going to
garage sales, spending $3,
and making $100 on eBay
is stunningly practical.
If you have a smartphone,
which unbelievably
people that are homeless,
on welfare, do.
Everybody has one
no matter what your
financial situation
is it seems that
almost everybody's
gotten to a place where
they have a smartphone;
which is incredible
and is maybe the most
optimistic thing I know in life.
This can happen.
And so last weekend
I just did what I always do,
which is I showed people.
By the way it was great weekend.
By the way one crazy
thing, stuffed animals.
- That's what you mentioned.
- Yeah, stuffed animals.
Here's why.
They're at every garage sale
and consistently they're
50 cents or a dollar.
And consistently they're
$10 to $20 on eBay.
If you know what to look for.
Disney store exclusives.
- That's where it's at?
- That's a good one.
And by the way,
DRock you know this,
you have to understand,
here's the pay off for me.
It's Friday,
this happened Saturday.
25 emails already.
- So, you're constantly
selling toys and stuff online?
- Not constantly,
I'm hot on it right now.
Ya know what I collect?
I collect people,
for sure at some level.
I love people, boy,
I really like people.
And in all our flaws
I really understand it.
- And they stay
with you too, right?
- Yeah I have great retention.
But even if they don't,
I just genuinely like people.
I understand people.
It's what I understand
innately the best.
And I have a lot
of empathy, a lot.
And I really want to
talk about real shit.
Right?
I wanna talk about,
you know how everybody's like
don't be scared go do it?
No, it's about who
you're scared to.
I wanna go that one step that
I think a lot or people...
Ya know what's funny?
The world is very interesting.
People that were born with
the gift that I was born with,
which is understanding people,
are unfortunately
not born with the same
other trait that
I have, which is
they use that to their leverage
to their financial benefit.
The thing that I'm most proud of
and why I believe
a lot of people
will show up to my funeral is
when you have what I have,
you usually sell it.
I'm giving it away for free.
And that's a big deal.
And that's why most people
don't talk about that next step
because that's the thing they
get paid $35,000 a month for,
when they coach you,
or life coach you,
or when you go to their island,
or this that and
the other thing.
Got it?
- Final question.
(mumbles) to get into
the social media saying,
"We can't not use it."
and the young
generation does it already.
You still see a lot of
frustration when people can't
build their followers
and you talk about this
quite a bit where it like...
- Well you might
not be interesting.
- Right.
(laughter)
So, I wanted to end on a high...
- We're gonna end
on a high, it's called
self-awareness.
- Yeah.
- Let's end on the greatest
high, self-awareness.
You might not be interesting
and or you may not know
how to communicate that
interesting in
today's world yet.
Nobody's entitled to followers.
You don't open
an Instagram account
and then
you win.
That's like buying a basketball
and thinking you're
going to the NBA.
(laughter)
- (Laughing) I love that.
So, listen Gary,
we are out of time, right?
We're out of time, but we
are gonna have you back.
So, I think you're going
back to your office
and then coming back.
- That is true. Not too far.
- So we'll see you
this afternoon.
- Soon.
- And thank you so much.
- Awesome.
Thanks for having me.
Thank you guys.
(audience applause)